on enchaîne avec la folie du jour pour
ça penser un truc hier à Marseille il y
a un dromadaire qui s'est échappé d'un
CEN mais moi ce weekend je rentrais de
de Gen rentré Damien et et ben il y a eu
un accident sur l'autoroute et il y a
deux sangliers qui étaient morts parce
qu'il y a une dame qui a tapé deux
sanglier sur
l'autoroute la dame la pauvre elle était
elle était au bout de sa vie elle était
choquée était en train de pleurer dans
sa voiture et les deux sangliers les
pauvres ils étaient morts des petit des
petits sangliers étaient morts sur le
sur l'autoroute ça m'a fait de la
peineou je jure vra ou ouis ou oua faut
pas en vouloir au sangliers parce qu'on
rappelle quand même que c'est pas les
sangliers qui traversent la route c'est
la route qui traverse la
for RA m'ont fait de la peine de petits
sangliers les PE et ils ont
pris Mar
ilass de la chance visiblement parce que
ça aurait pu être beaucoup plus je j
ouais é allongé bon voilàah il pas mort
le dromadaire il y a un dromire qui
s'est échappé d'un cirque il a créé un
sacré bordel fortement perturbé la
circulation
[Musique]
regardez j'adore les dromad il y a des
animaux comme ça qui ont des têtes de
tebé non mais il sont des
alors j'ai rien contre les DROM mais
c'est vrai que tu tu es en classe tu as
pas envie de te mettre à côté d'un
dromeadire tu te dis c'est pas voilà il
a pas un QI de ouf non mais sans
déconner c'est vrai un drô mal il y a
des animaux comme ça ils ont vraiment
des têtes de tebé est-ce que vous avez
d'autres animaux comme ça qu'il on
l'autruche exactement l'autruche a les
têtes de teb c'est vrai le lama il a une
tête de tebé c'est
vrai le dindon a une tête de tebé
exactement je vous jure que c'est vrai
la truite
[Rires]
ouais
j'uris dit l'arrê j'ai dit la truite s
sors la meilleure phrase c'est celle qui
va sortir j'ai failli dire l'arrê j'ai
dit la
truite franchement non mais c'est ça la
VAN c'est ça la VAN la vraie van elle
est là la vane elle est là non mais il y
a des animaux qui ont l'air intelligents
c'est quoi votre animal préféré vous par
exemple vous c'est quoi le lion ah ouais
rien d'un lion en plus toi comment non
franchement non excuse-moi frère c'est
mon signe astrologique oui mais pour moi
si tu éta un animal voilà donnez-moi
votre animal préféré je vais vous dire
l'animal que que je vois en vous ah
ouais tu vois le lion oui toi
franchement lion mais frère franchement
je vois le pigeon je te jure que c'est
vrai mais je te jure que c'est vrai
c'est pas hor mais je vous jure que
c'est vrai en plus c'est vrai je vois il
vois le lion je vois le pigeon qu'est-ce
que tu vois toi moi une panthère non la
lre toi j'allais dire
la tuas rien d'une panthère rien non
tuas rien d'une pantère quoi la loutre
c'est quoi pourquoi j'ai l'air d'une
loutre c'est hyper mignon l'air d'une
lre je te dis tu as l'air d'une loutre
tuas rien à voir mign une loutre AC ouis
mais non mais tu as rien à voir avec une
pantère toi le taureau non tu as rien à
voir avec un taureau frère ah bon ah non
frère non franchement non tuas rien à
voir avec un taureau to vois comment
franchement ouaisc le royale quoiy
Roy non sans rigoler toi non toi je te
vois genre en pont en PR ouais ah ouais
avec ou ouais jeis pas comme ça tu vois
ouais non et en sourire comme tu vois
quoi ça sourit genre tu fais des bailes
comme c'est tuis je te vois comm toi tu
qui moi j'adore la girafe la girafe non
tu as rien d' Gira rien
GIR du tout une Gira c'est une tête de
teb arrêtez les girafes tu les vois bien
les giraes es sont comm avec longinch
il a pas tort sur ça mais ça tê d'un
tebé arrêtez moi mes enfants m' dit
toujours girafe
po rien à voir toi justement toi toi tu
es une panthère moi toi tu es une pantè
bagera Baguera non non pas Baguera c'est
une panthère toi un cheval non pas du
tout ah je cours très
viteas rien tu as rien d'un cheval et
quoi alors pour moi pour moi à la base
c'est votre animal préféré tuas dit ah
oui c'est vrai ou ah
oui non pour moi pour moi toi toi tu es
une marmotte ah peut-être c'est une
marmotte comme ça c'est quoi ton animal
préféré toi la chauve-souris la
chauve-souris elle dort ou elle
[Applaudissements]
suce je ne peux plus bien rest secondes
ilér il casse il casse toutes les
séquences franchement il
mais il casse toutes les séquences non
mais franchement c'est c'est c'est
catastrophique oui vous ben donc
j'enlève panère donc je vais dire
dauphin dauphin dans la mer le soleil ça
rigole mal non toi c'est c'est plus une
Solle
une je P c'est vrai tu es plus une Solle
qu'un dauphin oui vous moi tous les
félins ah ouais les chats les lions les
P du tout moi je teis plus en cafard non
mais vous Kelly bah moi aussi je partais
sur le dauphin mais plus dans le sens je
me fauile et je rigole ah ouais ouais je
vois pas du tout en dauphin moi ah vous
voyez en quoi vous non elle je la vois
plus en Yenne en
y tu vois elle rigole comme ça tu vois
ça va c'est gentil c'est très gentil
vous avez changé d'animal les 10 non
pourquoi il fallit changer toujours la
chauve-souris oui donc votre animal
préféré c'est la chauve-souris et alors
bah c'est Batman ah pas mal ah pas mal
ah oui je peux plus le bler bah et vous
Cyril alors du coup quoi bah votre
animal mon animal préféré vous le savez
c'est le tigre moi je dirais plus que
c'est vous laen B c'est moi la hienne
bah oui moi la hienne bah oui bah le
rireenne r ça rien à voir j'ai pas du
tout un rire de Yenne j'ai un rire
de non non non non non mais moi moi moi
c'est le tigre mon animal préféré et
tout le monde dit que je ressemble
plutôt à un tigre de Tunisie ouais
tigre euh il y a un élève qui a cassé
une assiette à la cantine ou ah ouais
ses parents doivent payer 3,28 € vous
avez vu cette histoire ouais ça me
rappelle l'histoire du du vase de
Soisson ouais vous connaissez Lesur du
vase de Soisson B oui c'est qui sa qui a
cassé le vase de Soisson c'est qui
Soisson c'est qui qui a cassé le vase le
vase de Soisson connaissez l'histoire du
vase de Soisson quand tu au toilettes
non c'est quoi
l'histoire quand tu connais l'histoire
du vase de Soisson c'est quoi la vanne
ouais dis-moi tu connais l'histoire du V
oh là là pour vousir raconter comme ça
j'ai du mal franchement non parce qu'on
l' connait en classe ça le vase deçon et
moi mon père un jour il m'a dit le prof
il est arrivé il m'a dit ouais même le
vase de Soisson il veut pas en parler
alors que il a cassé et combien il coûte
ce
vage mais c'est quoi l'histoire c'est
quoi l'histoire du vase de Soisson je
crois que c'est ver saintgetoris qui
avait cassé qui avait cassé une assiette
qui qui vait ch c'est pas le GUID de
graine Clovis ou peut-être Clovis ah
Clovis peutêtre vous êtes comment au
niveau
d'histoire Clov Clov moi je sur cl cl
Clov Clovis qui avait cassé une assiette
qui valait cher un prix Curel qui avait
fait exprès de la casser pour pas
qu'elle soit saisie et du coup quand des
années plus tard il a été capturé on lu
a dit souviens-toi du vas deçon il l'a
décapité
bravo bon alors c'est incompréhensible à
réag son pre on parle d'un gamin de 12
ans qui casse une assiette pour la
première fois sans le faire exprès on va
demander aux parents de la rembourser je
trouve ça mesquin ça représente quoi une
assiette à quoi correspond exactement
cette somme de 3 28 j'en ai parlé autour
de moi personne ne comprend si mon
Beaufils avait cassé volontairement bien
sûr qu'il il devrait être sanctionné je
trouvais ça normal mais là ce n'est pas
le cas c'est vrai que le P il pas
faitèsanch la base de CER des TR la on
l' tous fait tout le monde CR génial en
plus là il a pas fait exprès il pas fait
exès faitè vérité prière fois il a 12
ans c'est la première fois alors
l'établissement dit c'est dans le
règlement intérieur mais ce sera un qu'
aurait fait
exprès détruire les jette l'argent à la
gueule tiens por ton assiette mais le
père s'est vangé parce qu'il a il a
remboursé en pièce de 1 centime ouais
mais il est marrant ouais c'est marrant
ça c'est marrant V j'aime bien quand
elle est là tu vois elle a toujours le
petite l'info BFM tu vois l'info BFM
l'info qui sert à rien
euh c'est pour qui c'est sy j'adore mais
non j'adore t'inquiète pas j'adore
arrête un peu oh là là j'adore